.
Wow, hello.
- Hier, unser Haus.
(Mann) Hey, Hugo,
hier in der Ecke ist dein Zimmer.
Ich will
einen Ausblick auf die Berge.
Ein Traum
soll schon bald Wirklichkeit werden:
Inmitten der Berge,
im Berner Oberland,
baut sich Familie Knecht ein Haus.
Alles fängt verheissungsvoll an.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass
unsere Kinder ein Zuhause haben.
Doch die Ereignisse überstürzen sich:
Es kommt zu Lieferengpässen.
Aus diesem Grund
mussten wir das Bauprojekt stoppen.
Für die Familie eine Zerreissprobe.
... wo Hugo gerade
etwas runterkommt.
(Englisch)
Es gibt keinen Rückzugsort für mich.
Runter!
- That's not okay for me.
Als es auf der Baustelle
endlich losgeht,
wird Mutter Erica Knecht krank.
Auf unserer Familie
lastet schon ein riesiger Druck.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Lyra, warte.
- (Kind) I'm making it right now.
Hier wird das Haus stehen.
Dann haben wir vier Schlafzimmer
und im oberen Stock ein Badezimmer.
Hier ist die Welt noch in Ordnung:
Meiringen, Ende 2021.
In einem Jahr schon
sollte auf diesem Grundstück
das Haus der Familie Knecht stehen.
Wollt ihr noch eine gute Nachricht?
Dann könnt ihr so viel trampeln,
wie ihr wollt.
Weil niemand mehr unter uns ist.
Es wird toll,
nicht mehr in einer Wohnung zu sein,
denn unsere Kinder
sind wirklich laut.
Nicht laut, lebendig.
Ich hoffe,
es wird alles entspannter.
Dann geht unser eigenes Zeug kaputt.
Das macht vieles einfacher.
Es wird alles gut.
Dass sich der Hausbau
um Monate verzögern wird
und sie als Familie
an ihre Grenzen kommen -
das ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt
alles noch weit weg.
Stella.
Mittagessen von Chefkoch Rolf Knecht
für seine Familie.
Eher selten, dass am Mittag
alle zusammen am Tisch sitzen.
Vater Rolf arbeitet 100 %
und die gebürtige Kanadierin
Erica Knecht
zu 90 % als Head of Admission.
Die beiden haben drei Kinder:
die zu diesem Zeitpunkt
elfjährige Stella,
der achtjährige Hugo
und die fünfjährige Lyra.
Die Zweizimmerwohnung in Meringen
ist eng,
die Vorfreude aufs Haus riesig.
Es gibt diesen bestimmten Look
von Schweizer Küchen.
Was ist falsch an Schweizer Küchen?
- Sie sehen alle gleich aus.
Schau, das ist
die typische Schweizer Küche.
Ich finde,
es gibt keinen individuellen Stil.
* Poltern *
* Ein Kind beginnt zu weinen. *
Like you often see ...
* Lautes Poltern *
Die zu kleine Wohnung
wird immer wieder Thema sein.
Die Familie
wohnt erst seit einem Jahr hier.
Zuvor war sie
während Jahren in Asien.
Mein Name ist Rolf,
ich bin kulinarischer Direktor
von Grand Hyatt Kuala Lumpur.
Seit 2006 bin ich dabei
und war schon überall in Asien.
Es ist fast
wie ein wahr gewordener Traum,
denn mein Vater
war einer der ersten kulinarischen
Chefs von Hyatt in Asien.
Kurz vor Corona nahm die Familie
Abschied von Asien und kam,
nach fast 20 Jahren Ausland,
zurück in die Schweiz.
Ich hatte einfach genug vom Job.
Man fängt immer wieder bei null an,
wenn man umzieht -
sowohl bei der Arbeit
als auch im sozialen Leben.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir umzogen, mussten
wir unsere Kinder entwurzeln.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass Stella ein Zuhause braucht.
Für sie wurde es
mit jedem Umzug schwieriger:
neue Schule, neue Freunde.
Ein Haus zu kaufen,
war wie ein Bekenntnis für mich:
Hier bleiben wir jetzt.
Am Anfang
steht die Skizze dieses Hauses.
Wir werden auch einen Garten haben,
in dem unsere Kinder spielen können.
Und sozusagen über Nacht entscheiden
sie sich für dieses Projekt.
Es ist ein totaler Schuss ins Blaue.
Im Prinzip
geben wir eine knappe Million aus,
basierend
auf einem dreiseitigen Baubeschrieb
und einer Skizze der Aussenfassade
und des Badezimmers.
Dieses Spontane
passt ein bisschen zu uns.
Es ist ein kalkuliertes Risiko.
Keine Ahnung, was dabei rauskommt.
Ein Termin bei der Bank steht an.
Für den Hausbau
müssen sich die beiden Berufstätigen
immer mehr Zeit freischaufeln.
(Frau) Ich glaube,
es ist auf gutem Weg.
Sie sprechen von März. Ich sprach
gestern mit dem Architekten.
Ja, ich glaube, das läuft.
Die Baubewilligung haben wir schon.
Die finanzielle Tragbarkeit fürs Haus
wird jetzt definitiv berechnet.
Beim Jahreseinkommen
habe ich den Betrag eingetragen,
den Sie zurzeit gemeinsam verdienen.
That's our income now.
- Genau.
Unten sieht man
einen orangen Bereich.
Dieser sollte grün sein.
It should be green
and now it's orange.
Right.
- Mission: Impossible.
In der Schweiz ist es wirklich
schwierig, ein Haus zu kaufen.
Wenn man in Kanada
an einem Ort vergleichbar
mit Meiringen bauen würde,
wäre das absolut erschwinglich.
Rolf und Erica Knecht haben Glück:
Sie werden sich das Haus
trotz zu wenig Eigenkapital
und zu wenig Einkommen
leisten können - dank Erbschaft.
Diese Erbschaft bzw. Schenkung, die
wir von meinen Eltern erhalten ...
Können wir kurz schauen,
was dann das Maximum wäre?- Ja.
Nun ist der Bereich hier unten
grün - 34 %.
Bezüglich der Tragbarkeit
ist es also kein Problem.
D.h., die Hypothek
betrüge dann 680'000 Fr.
Für mich ist es extremer Stress.
Ich gehe nicht gern mit Geld um ...
... und dann noch all das.
Es ist schon stressig.
Wenn ich Erica nicht hätte,
wäre es noch viel schlimmer.
Was Rolf Knecht damit meint:
Sie habe das Familienbudget im Griff,
er nicht.
Vielen Dank.
- Ich danke Ihnen.
Frohe Festtage.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Wintereisbahnbetrieb
auf dem Dorfplatz in Meiringen.
# But the fire is so delightful.
# And since we've no place to go ...
Rolf Knecht macht Freiwilligenarbeit
und kocht
ein indonesisches Nasi Goreng.
Ich war in Indonesien.
- Ich habe vier Jahre dort gewohnt.
Jakarta.
Aber ich war verantwortlich
für eine Hotelkette
und reiste fast
in ganz Indonesien herum.
Ich arbeitete viel mit Schokofarmern
und Kaffeebauern zusammen.
Wir waren fast überall.
Rolf Knecht will sich an seinem
neuen Wohnort Meiringen integrieren.
Dann machen wir zweimal 6 Fr.
Ich gebe euch eine grosse Portion.
Ah, das ist gut.
- Ja, ja.
Ich finde es super, hier zu kochen
und der Community
etwas zurückzugeben.
So findet man Anschluss
und lernt viele Leute kennen.
Das ist spannend, es ist super.
Die ganze Familie ist da.
(Lyra, Englisch) Ich bin hungrig.
Können wir etwas zu essen holen?
Ja, hol dir was.
- Mama, komm.
Was möchtest du?
Eat it.
Familie Knecht ist voller Hoffnung.
Die älteste Tochter Stella
hat sich in der neuen Umgebung
gut eingelebt
und in der Schule
Freundinnen gefunden.
* Sie singen ein fröhliches Lied. *
Die Familie rechnet damit,
dass sie Weihnachten in einem Jahr
bereits im neuen Haus feiern kann.
Fünf Monate später
ist die Welt eine andere:
In der Ukraine
ist ein Krieg ausgebrochen,
die Holzpreise sind massiv gestiegen
und es gibt Lieferschwierigkeiten
diverser Baumaterialien.
Das Bauprojekt stockt.
Um Klarheit zu schaffen,
gibt es ein Treffen
mit den Architekten Alexandra Reimann
und Patrick Sidler.
Aus diesem Grund
mussten wir das Bauprojekt stoppen,
um zu entscheiden,
wie es weitergeht.
Wir klärten das Ganze
auch mit den Unternehmern ab
und merkten, dass es zurzeit
sinnlos ist, anzufangen.
Die Zeitschiene funktioniert nicht.
Daher mussten wir überlegen,
wie wir vorgehen.
Wir beschlossen,
es in den Herbst zu verschieben.
Wir werden im Herbst starten,
während des Winters
eine Pause machen
und im Februar oder März 2023
den Holzbau aufrichten.
What happens if it's like
a really, really wet spring?
Wenn es
einen total nassen Frühling gibt -
heisst das,
dass wir erst im Sommer beginnen?
Nein, nein.
Sie sind also
ziemlich zuversichtlich.- Ja.
Das sind Verschiebungen,
die wenige Wochen betreffen.
Man wird immer ein Zeitfenster
fürs Aufrichten finden.
Okay, einfach damit ihr wisst:
Jeder Monat, den wir länger
in unserer Wohnung bleiben müssen,
kostet mich fünf Jahre
meines Lebens.
Ich komme und helfe.
I'm good with the hammer.
Die Verschiebung des Baus um ein Jahr
ist ein Riesendämpfer
für die Familie,
denn die Wohnsituation
hat sich zugespitzt.
Deine Sonnenbrille ist mir zu gross.
Die fünfjährige Lyra hat die seltene
Augenkrankheit Axenfeld Rieger.
Schon zehn Operationen hat das
Mädchen seit der Geburt hinter sich.
Erneut steht eine an.
Für die Familie
eine von vielen Belastungen.
Die älteste Tochter Stella
hat die Diagnose Asperger
und bräuchte Rückzugsmöglichkeiten.
Genau wie Bruder Hugo,
der auf dem ADHS-Spektrum ist.
Doch Rückzug
gibt's in dieser Wohnung nicht.
Hier ist der Eingang, der direkt
in unser Schlafzimmer führt.
Hier schlafen meine Frau und ich,
aber es ist auch ein Rückzugsort
für unsere älteste Tochter,
wenn es ihr zu viel wird.
Hier ist das Wohnzimmer,
das Esszimmer und die Küche.
Und ...
... hier hinten in der Ecke
sind wahlweise ...
... Hugo oder Lyra.
Das ist ihr secret spot,
ihr secret corner.
Es kommt darauf an.
Hier ist das Kinderzimmer,
in dem Hugo
gerade etwas runterkommt.
Im Kinderzimmer ist die Person,
die gerade am meisten Ruhe braucht,
damit sie
wirklich runterkommen kann.
That is just creepy.
Es gibt keinen Rückzugsort
in diesem Haus.
Es fühlt sich an,
als wäre mein Nervensystem
dauernd aktiviert,
denn es herrscht immer Chaos.
Geh weg.
Lyra, es geht nicht, wenn du
Hugos Spielzeug rumschmeisst.
Hör auf!
- Hugo, es ist nicht okay für mich.
* Hugo murrt. *
- Okay, es gibt Mittagessen.
Da wir wegen des Wohnens oder ...
... wegen des fehlenden Platzes
so viele Konflikte haben,
essen die, die Cannelloni mögen,
Cannelloni,
und für die Person, die sich
weigert, Cannelloni zu essen,
gibt es Älplermagronen.
Zudem können nicht alle
dieselbe Salatsauce essen.
Wenn wir nichts machen,
haben wir nach 1 Std. Konflikte.
Die Konflikte werden schlimmer,
weil niemand einen Rückzugsort hat
und alle wütend aufeinander sind.
Daher waren wir bzw. ich
der Meinung,
dass es einfacher ist,
30 Min. länger zu kochen.
Die Wohnung -
nur als Übergang gedacht -
wird zum Langzeitprovisorium.
Ich habe die Rückkehr in die Schweiz
idealisiert.
Ich dachte: "Wir kommen zurück
in die Schweiz und alles wird gut."
Ich dachte,
es sei besser für die Familie,
wir hätten mehr Zeit zu Hause,
das Wohnen sei einfacher
und wir hätten weniger Stress.
Ich habe es wirklich idealisiert.
Dann kommt man an und nichts ist so,
wie man es sich vorstellte.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt überlegen sich
Erica und Rolf Knecht Alternativen:
das Hausbauprojekt abbrechen,
eine andere Wohnung suchen.
Doch: Eine Mietwohnung für
eine fünfköpfige Familie zu finden,
ist schier unmöglich -
auch in Meiringen.
Schau, es wird ein Scheissjahr.
Aber es ist  e i n  Jahr.
Es sind nicht 20 Jahre.
Und ich werde 20 Jahre
in diesem Haus leben.
Ein chinesisches Sprichwort sagt:
"Du musst viel Bitterkeit essen."
Das machen wir jetzt.
Danach haben wir die süsse Erfahrung
eines Daheims für die Familie.
Und eigene Schlafzimmer.
- Mit einer Tür.
Wohneigentum
ist für viele hierzulande ein Traum.
Doch nur 30 % aller Schweizer
Haushalte haben das nötige Kapital,
um sich ein durchschnittliches
Einfamilienhaus leisten zu können.
(Mann) Voilà, stopp.
- Wie mache ich das?
Du kannst sie drehen.
Spatenstich - endlich.
Ein Rückzug vom Projekt wäre jetzt
mit hohen Kosten verbunden.
Wie war es?
- Es war cool.
Gute Arbeit.
Die Bauunternehmung
hat für Rolf und Erica Knecht
ein Spatenstich-Ritual vorbereitet.
* Rolf lacht. *
Ich trage die falschen Schuhe.
* Er lacht. *
(Mann) Wir haben schon
die erste Leitung erwischt.
Man muss die Probleme sofort aus dem
Weg schaffen, was? Der erste Unfall.
Ja ...
- Oh!
Eine schöne Leitung,
davon können wir noch mehr treffen.
Vielen Dank.
- Ich wünsche Ihnen alles Gute.
Danke.
Jetzt fühlt es sich
irgendwie real an.
Es ist so schräg,
wenn du dir vorstellst,
dass wir jetzt eigentlich
mit dem Bau fertig sein müssten.
Konzentrier dich aufs Positive.
Ja, ein Jahr. Ein Jahr.
In den nächsten drei Monaten
werden Baumeisterarbeiten ausgeführt.
Das Fundament wird gegossen,
die Kanalisation gemacht
und die Werkleitung angeschlossen.
Dann ruht das Projekt
über den Winter.
Es ist ein absolutes Privileg.
Ich bin schon seit jungen Jahren
politisch sehr stark links.
Als ich in St. Moritz wohnte,
führte ich jeweils
heisse Diskussionen
bezüglich der Villen,
die so viel Platz verschwenden,
oder als ich in Zürich arbeitete
bezüglich der besetzten Fabriken
beim Bahnhof.
Nun habe ich ein Haus.
Das ist ein extremer Gegensatz.
Meine Ausrede bzw. Justification
ist:
Wir bauen nachhaltig.
Wir bauen wirklich für uns.
Es ist kein Spekulationsobjekt,
keine Zweitwohnung,
die wir mal als Ferienwohnung
vermieten werden.
Es ist für uns.
Termin bei der Notarin in Meiringen.
Rolf Knechts Eltern knüpfen
ihre Schenkung an eine Bedingung.
Diese soll
schriftlich festgehalten werden.
Kommen Sie nur herein.
Dies ist das Dokument,
in dem vereinbart wird,
dass Sie bzw.
Ihre drei gemeinsamen Kinder
im Fall einer Trennung
oder Scheidung
weiterhin in der gemeinsamen
Liegenschaft wohnen dürfen -
zusammen mit
dem obhutsberechtigten Elternteil.
Es ist jedoch so,
dass ein Gericht im Streitfall
nicht an eine solche Vereinbarung
gebunden ist.
Im Streitfall würde ein Gericht im
Sinne des Kindeswohls entscheiden.
Ist das so in Ordnung für Sie?
(Englisch) Okay für dich
oder hast du Fragen?- No.
Obwohl rechtlich nicht bindend, sei
diese gemeinsame Erklärung wichtig,
sagen die Eltern von Rolf Knecht.
Es war eine Bedingung meiner Eltern.
Wir hätten das
wohl nicht so gemacht,
aber nun
haben wir es so unterschrieben,
um sicherzustellen, dass unsere
Kinder einen Ort zum Wohnen haben,
falls etwas passiert.
Ich bin sehr dankbar für
die Unterstützung von Rolfs Eltern.
Aber wie Rolf schon sagte:
Wir hätten es wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen anders gelöst.
Doch weil seine Eltern
so grosszügig sind,
ist es wichtig für mich,
ihr Anliegen ernst zu nehmen.
* Dynamische Klaviermusik *
Auf Wiedersehen. Danke.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Besuch bei der Architektin.
Rolf und Erica Knecht wollen
das Privathaus von Alexandra Reimann
nochmals besichtigen, um sich für
ihren Hausbau inspirieren zu lassen.
Hallo, kommt nur rein.
Ihr könnt die Schuhe auch
drinnen ausziehen.- Nein, nein.
Doch, doch.
Was ist das?
- Das ist Chromstahl.
Das ist Stahl?
- Genau, aber besonderer Chromstahl.
Wenn du ihn mit dem dort
vergleichst ...- Budgetmässig?
Das ist bestimmt ...
Das kostet viel.
Das kostet.
- It's expensive.
Ab jetzt ist Geld das grosse Thema.
Wunsch und Realität
klaffen weit auseinander.
Was gefällt, ist teuer,
z.B. weisse Glattputzwände.
Ihr könntet
auch nur gewisse Wände weiss machen.
Es müssen ja nicht alle Wände
weiss sein.
Ihr könntet damit spielen.
She is saying that there would be
wood, some walls would be white ...
Genau.
- ... Stella's room pink.- Yeah.
Also wirklich ...
- Du kannst sie zuknallen lassen.
Sie schliesst sich von selbst.
- Oh!
Rolf, unsere Kinder
werden das kaputt machen.
Ich weiss, aber schau:
Du träumst von Oberflächen,
ich von Schubladen.
Each their own.
- Das ist heute Standard.
Hier das Sitzfenster, das bei euch
auch vorgesehen ist.- Genau.
Kann man unter dem Sitzfenster
Schubladen montieren?- Ja.
Die Kinder können
auf dem Sitzfenster spielen.
Sie können stehen, die Schubladen
öffnen und Spiele hervorholen.
Das Besondere hier
ist die frei stehende Badewanne.
Sie ist nirgends eingebaut.
Sie benötigt halt viel Platz.
Das wäre bei euch aber möglich.
Ihr hättet genügend Platz.
We would have the space for
a free-standing bathtub like that.
Ich hoffe,
wir haben das Budget dafür.
Vielen Dank,
dass wir kommen durften.- Gern.
Das war super.
Wir haben sehr viel gelernt.
Für die frei stehende Badewanne
wird das Geld ausreichen.
Viele andere Träume
werden am Budget scheitern.
Wegen der Änderungswünsche
bahnen sich bereits jetzt
hohe Mehrkosten an.
* Sägemaschinen *
In der Zimmerei ist Hochbetrieb.
Ein Jahr zuvor war hier Stillstand.
Der Markt hatte verrückt gespielt.
Das ist vorbei.
Jetzt können wir loslegen.
Es war extrem: Dreischichtplatten
kosteten dreimal so viel wie 2019,
Anfang 2020.
Die Leimholzpreise
waren mehr als doppelt so hoch.
Das habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Das war eine Ausnahmesituation.
Die Zimmerei fertigt im Betrieb
Wände und Böden vor.
Vor Ort in Meiringen
werden dann die Elemente montiert.
Erica sagte:
"Thank you for building our home."
Ich sagte:
"Nein, das stimmt gar nicht."
"Wir bauen einfach ein Haus.
Das ist der technische Vorgang."
"A home is what you make out of it."
Zwei Monate später ist es so weit:
Die Holzwände werden aufgerichtet.
Honestly,
I think it's really interesting.
Für Erica und Rolf Knecht
eine riesige Erleichterung.
Es ist wirklich grossartig,
das zu sehen.
Ich bin glücklich.
Jetzt müssen
die definitiven Entscheidungen
für die Innenausstattung
gefällt werden.
Hier drüben wäre die Küche,
nicht wahr?- Genau.
Da wird es noch etwas Platz
haben dazwischen, oder?
Dort haben wir
einen Kühlschrank und ein Regal.
Ich glaube,
die Kücheninsel ist etwa hier.
Wie breit ist sie? 90 cm?
Der Innenausbau
ist Erica Knecht sehr wichtig.
Vom Standardobjekt,
das sie ursprünglich gekauft haben,
weichen die beiden immer wieder ab.
Aktuelle Mehrkosten deshalb:
40'000 Fr.
Ich habe mit meinem Vater
darüber gesprochen und er sagte:
"Wenn du kannst,
mach wirklich, was du willst."
Ein guter Rat.
Wir bauen nur einmal.
Wir vergessen manchmal,
dass die Leute einmal bauen.
Wir, die immer wieder Häuser bauen,
sind uns das manchmal
zu wenig bewusst.
... that this is
something unique for you.
And special.
Es ist gut, wenn ihr uns sagt,
wie speziell es für euch ist.
Das macht es auch speziell für uns.
Es ist das erste Mal,
dass wir ein Haus haben,
das erste Mal, dass wir für immer
an einem Ort bleiben werden
und unsere Kinder
Wurzeln schlagen können.
Erica Knecht ist
zu diesem Zeitpunkt krankgeschrieben
und vorübergehend in einer Klinik.
Diesen Moment habe sie nicht
verpassen wollen, darum sei sie hier.
Ihre Diagnose: Burn-out.
Mit dem Bau habe die Krankheit
nichts zu tun, sagt Erica Knecht.
Im Gegenteil:
Was hier geschehe, freue sie.
Krank habe sie die Situation
am Arbeitsplatz gemacht.
Ein Burn-out ist, als
würdest du dich selbst verlieren.
Alles ist dir zu viel.
Du fühlst dich komplett überfordert.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass ich vor dem Computer sass
und nicht mehr entscheiden konnte,
in welchem Ordner
ich die E-Mails ablege.
Oder ich stand in der Küche
und fragte mich,
wie ich die Spülmaschine
ausräumen muss.
Folgendes habe ich gelernt:
Ein Burn-out ist nicht das,
was du denkst.
Ein Burn-out ist nicht,
dass du zu wenige Sonntage draussen
verbringst und ein Buch liest.
Ein Burn-out ist nicht,
dass du zu viele Stunden arbeitest.
Ein Burn-out
hat nur mit dem Zusammenspiel
zwischen Individuum und der Struktur
zu tun.
Mitten in dieser schwierigen Zeit
wechselt Rolf Knecht den Job.
Weisswein oder Rotwein
zum Ablöschen?- Rotwein.
Einen guten.
Ja.
Er wird Küchenchef
in einem Parkhotel am Thunersee
und führt ein Team von
30 Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern.
Er will im Betrieb Akzente setzen:
z.B. mehr Angebote aus der Region
für die Region.
Jobwechsel,
Krankheit und ein Hausbau:
Wie hoch ist derzeit die Belastung?
Momentan ist sie ...
... hoch -
wegen Erica, die zurzeit krank ist,
wegen des Hausbaus
und des Neuanfangs.
Aber ich dachte: "Wenn ich
die Stelle jetzt nicht annehme,
ist sie weg, wenn der Zeitpunkt
für mich günstig wäre."
Entlastung und Freizeit gibt es kaum.
Die privaten Veränderungen
sind für die Familie einschneidend.
Und der Kostendruck auf der Baustelle
steigt.
In den letzten zwei Jahren hatte ich
manchmal schon einen Durchhänger.
Ich dachte: "Das wird zu viel."
"Es geht in eine Richtung,
die wir uns ..."
Man fragt sich schon,
ob man sich das leisten kann.
Man ist irgendwie ...
Wie nennt man das?
Mitgegangen, mitgefangen oder so.
Man kann gar nicht mehr zurück.
Wir könnten das Bauprojekt
eigentlich nur abbrechen,
wenn wir das halb fertige Haus
an jemanden verkaufen würden,
sodass wir die Hypotheken abbezahlen
könnten, die wir aufgenommen haben.
Es gibt schon Momente,
in denen man ...
Man ist am Telefon,
eine neue E-Mail geht ein
und man sieht nur den Betreff:
"Zusatzkosten" oder "Mehrkosten".
Dann öffnet man die E-Mail
1 Std. lang nicht,
weil man nicht wissen will,
was wieder mehr kostet.
Und dann ... Das ist schon stressig.
Rolf Knecht hat bei den Abrechnungen
festgestellt,
dass ihre Änderungswünsche
hohe Mehrkosten generieren.
Um zu sparen, würde er gerne direkt
mit den Händlern verhandeln.
Doch das geht nicht.
Er will von den Architekten wissen,
warum.
Hallo.
- Hallo, Rolf.- Hallo.
Da wir diese besonderen Kacheln, die
grössere Badewanne usw. auswählten,
hat sich das ziemlich ...
... summiert.
- ... summiert.
Wir hatten
ziemlich viele Änderungswünsche.
Meine Frage ist nun:
Wieso muss das Ganze zuerst
an den Architekten gesandt werden?
Wieso kann mir der Küchenbauer die
Zeichnungen nicht direkt schicken,
damit ich Änderungswünsche
anbringen kann?
Wieso läuft das über den Architekten
und nicht direkt über mich
als Kunden?
Du bist davon ausgegangen,
dass ihr die Bauherren seid.
Genau, ich dachte:
"Wer zahlt, befiehlt."
Ja, also ...
- So in der Art.
Das ist ...
Das ist nicht so.
Ihr seid die Käufer.
Für uns wäre es viel einfacher,
wenn der Käufer unsere Vorschläge
einfach umsetzen würde.
Dann gäbe es für euch
keine Mehrkosten,
und es sähe so aus,
wie wir es geplant haben.
Beim Eichenparkettboden könnt ihr
zwischen hell und dunkel wählen.
Die Platten sind 30 x 60 cm gross
und ihr könnt
zwischen hell und dunkel wählen.
Da haben wir keinen Aufwand.
Wir hatten einen Planungsaufwand,
aber den tragen wir.
Dann können wir es
wie geplant umsetzen.
Wenn jedoch vier Käufer -
dies ist teils der Fall -
komplett etwas anderes wollen,
müssen wir es
ja immer wieder anpassen,
es dem Unternehmer vorlegen, es
auf der Baustelle koordinieren ...
Dann habt ihr anstelle von 50 Std.
200 Std. Aufwand.
Das wäre zu viel, aber ...
- Was auch immer.
... wir haben
wirklich viel mehr Aufwand,
als wenn wir dem Verkäufer
nicht die Wahl liessen,
alles selbst zu bestimmen.
Architektin Reimann sagt,
von allen vier Käufern
hätten Knechts
am meisten Änderungswünsche gehabt.
Künftig würden sie ihrer Kundschaft -
nicht zuletzt
aufgrund dieser Erfahrungen -
weniger Wahlmöglichkeiten anbieten.
Ein paar Wochen später: Die Zimmerei
montiert die Holzfassade.
Bei einem spontanen Baustellenbesuch
ist Rolf Knecht überrascht,
wie viel Handarbeit dahintersteckt.
Müsst ihr alles auf der Baustelle
nach Mass zuschneiden?
Kann man das nicht im Voraus machen?
Nein,
die Details sind etwas speziell,
daher machen wir das
auf der Baustelle.
Cool.
Ein riesiger Aufwand.
- Ja, aber später sieht es gut aus.
So kriegt man den Tag rum.
- So ist es.
700 Arbeitsstunden brauchen
die Zimmerleute für die Aussendämmung
und Holzabdeckung des Hauses.
Hausbesitzer Knecht wird
in die Präzisionsarbeit eingeführt.
Das wird hier ...
Dieses Detail,
durch das man hineinblicken kann ...
Ah, das wird nicht verputzt?
- Nein.
Das bleibt so, damit man mehr sieht?
- Genau.
Deshalb müssen wir hier streichen,
sonst ...
... würde das helle Holz
hervorstechen.
Cool. Ich finde es megaschön.
Jetzt habe ich wirklich das Gefühl,
dass es vorwärtsgeht.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich herkomme,
hat sich etwas verändert.
So sieht man,
wo das Geld hinfliesst.
Jede einzelne Latte zuzuschneiden,
ist ein riesiger Aufwand.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
* Dynamische Klaviermusik *
Seit drei Jahren
beschäftigen sich Rolf und
Erica Knecht nun mit ihrem Hausbau.
Das Bauprojekt habe ihr Leben
und ihre Beziehung verändert,
sagen die beiden.
* Kuhglocken *
Geh unter die Bäume in den Schatten,
dann werden die Gläser dunkler,
äh, heller, pardon.
Zuvor hatten wir den Luxus,
dass wir in unserem Leben eigentlich
nichts entscheiden mussten.
Mein Arbeitgeber
traf die Entscheidungen.
Das war ein Vorteil,
aber auch ein Nachteil,
der uns letztlich zu viel wurde.
Aber es ist schon
ein Luxus-Lifestyle.
Überall, wo wir hingingen,
hatten wir eine Wohnung
und diverse andere Dinge.
Nun, da wir unser Zuhause
gemeinsam selbst definieren,
habe ich den Eindruck,
dass wir zusammengewachsen sind.
Wir haben vielleicht
auch einen anderen ...
... approach,
eine andere Art und Weise,
wie wir unsere Konflikte austragen.
Wow!
So viele Hände.
Wie viele Finger hast du, Hugo?
* Hugo kichert. *
Meine Güte!
Oh-oh!
Willst du es auch versuchen?
- Nein, danke.
Ich glaube, Rolf hat
einige zentrale Dinge verstanden.
Unsere Beziehung hat sich vertieft.
Er weiss jetzt, wie wichtig mir
gleichberechtigte Finanzen sind.
Und ich glaube auch, er weiss jetzt,
wie wichtig mir
meine Wohnumgebung ist,
auch wenn es manchmal Details sind.
Es hilft meiner mentalen Gesundheit.
Erica Knecht
geht es gesundheitlich besser.
Sie ist zurück aus der Klinik.
Die Kinder
haben sich in Meringen eingelebt,
haben Freundschaften geschlossen,
alle sind angekommen.
Noch knapp einen Monat
bis zur Schlüsselübergabe.
Die Überbauung
wird pünktlich fertig werden.
Rolf Knechts Eltern -
die "Sponsoren" -
sehen zum ersten Mal
das fast fertige Haus.
Hier kommt noch eine Wand hin.
- Ja.
Mir gefällt es.
Absolut.
Wir sind froh,
dass sie es machen konnten.
Der wäre dort hinten.
- Genau.
Nein, der Schuhschrank ist hier.
Dort ist eher die Garderobe
für die Jacken, Rucksäcke usw.
Hier kommt ein Schrank hin.
Wie viel Arbeit im Haus steckt,
veranschaulicht Hausbesitzer Knecht
seinen Eltern
am Beispiel der Hausfassade.
Das ist
wieder typische schweizerisch:
Damit es in den Ecken
auch gleich aussieht,
strichen sie alles nochmals nach,
bevor sie es hineinstülpten,
sodass man in den Ecken
kein weisses Holz sieht.
Das ist ...
- Das ist Schweizer Handwerkskunst.
Jawohl.
Aber wenn man 125 Fr. pro Stunde
verrechnet ...
Uns geht es primär darum, zu sehen,
was aus unserem Geld geworden ist.
Sie müssen nicht warten,
bis wir tot sind.
Ich freue mich, zu sehen,
dass ihre Kinder
nun hier gross werden dürfen
und dass sie hier Freiheiten haben,
die sie in Asien nie hatten.
Das ist ein ungeahnter Freiraum
für die Kinder.
(Vater) Die Kinder -
insbesondere Hugo - sagen,
dass sie nicht mehr zurückwollen.
Sie wollen hierbleiben.
Das ist schön.
* Dynamische Musik *
Hello, quick question ...
Drei Wochen später:
Tag der Hausübergabe.
Die Familie
ist am Packen für den Umzug.
Das kann nicht fliegen.
- Ist das neu?- Nein.
Den Fernseher nehmen wir heute Abend
nicht mit.- Doch.
Sicher nicht. Wir haben dort
noch gar kein Internet, Hugo.
Ich habe mir das
total romantisch vorgestellt.
Von Freitag bis Sonntag
habe ich frei,
am Freitag übernehmen wir das Haus,
am Samstag und Sonntag packen wir
und am Montag kommen sie.
Nun ja ...
- Hat nicht geklappt.
Stolpergefahr.
Am ersten Abend will ein Teil
der Familie im neuen Haus campieren.
Da oben.
Rolf Knecht sucht einen Schlafsack.
* Rolf seufzt. *
Stella?
Hast du gepackt?
- Nein, ich komme nicht mit.
Sie kommt nicht mit uns.
Es ist nicht cool,
wenn der Vater dabei ist.
Wenn man 13 ist ...
- Du bleibst mit Mama hier?
Ja.
- Okay.
Ich habe vor zwei Wochen
mit Packen begonnen
und fühlte mich extrem organisiert -
jetzt nicht mehr.
Es ist, als wärst du
mit voller Fahrt unterwegs
und plötzlich verlierst du ein Rad
und noch was
und alles fällt auseinander.
So fühlt es sich hier drinnen an.
Mitten im Durcheinander
müssen die Eltern los -
für die Schlüsselübergabe.
Hallo, Rolf.
- Salü.
Herzlich willkommen.
Ich übergebe euch die Schlüssel.
Dann könnt ihr rein.
- Ihr könnt euer Haus öffnen.
Die Hausübergabe
ist ein offizieller Akt:
Die Besitzer müssen begutachten,
ob alles wie abgemacht da ist
und funktioniert.
The explanation things.
- Die Gebrauchsanleitungen.
Im Eingangsbereich entdeckt
Erica Knecht eine Unsauberkeit.
(Patrick)
Hier braucht es noch etwas Farbe.
Architekt und Architektin notieren,
was es noch zu erledigen gilt.
Architektin Reimann macht
auf einen Planungsfehler aufmerksam,
der noch behoben wird.
(Alexandra)
Man kommt knapp nicht vorbei.
Und die melden sich dann bei uns?
Mit zwei Dingen, die fehlen,
haben die neuen Hausbesitzenden
nicht gerechnet:
Beim Ofen
ist nur ein Loch in der Decke
und im oberen Stock
sind zwei Kinderzimmer offen.
Ich dachte,
hier hätten wir eine Schiebetür.
Ähm ...
Gewisse Dinge haben wir
nicht aufmerksam genug gelesen,
z.B., ob der Ofen
im Preis inbegriffen ist oder nicht.
Wir dachten, er wäre inbegriffen.
Nun merkten wir,
dass er nicht inbegriffen ist.
Das habt ihr erst heute
herausgefunden?- Ja.
Ich dachte,
der Ofen wäre im Preis inbegriffen.
Ich habe es
nicht aufmerksam genug gelesen.
Okay.
- Aber das ist mein Fehler.
Ich habe das nicht ...
Du merktest vorhin, dass der Ofen ...
- ... nicht inbegriffen ist.
Ah, du meintest sogar,
er stünde hier.
Ja, aber das ist
ganz klar mein Fehler.- Okay.
Das ging bei mir
in dem ganzen Chaos völlig unter.
Für mich ist der Rest des Hauses
viel wichtiger -
z.B., dass die Kacheln
für Erica am richtigen Ort sind usw.
Das wurde alles
in dem Zeitraum definiert,
als es etwas holprig war.
Dass das klappte,
ist für mich die Hauptsache.
Ob es einen Ofen
oder eine Schiebetür gibt,
ist weniger wichtig.
Ofen und Tür
müssen sie selbst einbauen.
Andere kleine Mängel
übernimmt das Architekturbüro.
Damit ist der Bau
offiziell übergeben.
Cool.
Die Geduld,
die ihr uns entgegengebracht habt,
lässt uns sehr viel Freude
am Haus haben.
Ihr habt auf kleinste Details
Rücksicht genommen.
Das finde ich wichtig.
Denn wenn ich jetzt etwas nicht mag,
werde ich es die nächsten 20 Jahre
nicht mögen.
Und es würde von Tag zu Tag
schlimmer.
Weil ihr Geduld mit uns hattet,
ist das nicht passiert.
Vielen Dank.
- Danke schön.
Tschau.
- Vielen Dank.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
Abfahrt mit dem Gepäck
für die erste Nacht.
Die Familie hat kein Auto und
pendelt zu Fuss oder mit dem Fahrrad
zwischen alter Wohnung
und neuem Haus.
I know.
Okay, here it is.
- Cool.
Die Kinder sehen das fertige Haus
zum ersten Mal.
Schau hier, der Schrank. Siehst du,
wie viel Platz da ist?- Oh!
Papa, du hast gesagt,
wir hätten einen Garten.
Wir haben einen Garten.
- Das ist kein Garten.
Der Garten ist rundum.
Da ist noch kein Gras.
Das kommt noch.
Kleine Enttäuschungen
und kleine Freuden.
Nach drei Jahren
sind sie nun also in ihrem Haus.
Ich hoffe, unser Leben
wird sich komplett verändern.
Die Kinder werden nie mehr streiten,
sie werden Schuhe und Kleider
immer schön hinstellen
und das Haus
wird nie mehr schmutzig sein.
Rolf,
hast du auch einen Zukunftswunsch?
Nein, ich wünsche mir
einfach etwas weniger Hektik.
Einfach ...
... ankommen
und etwas weniger Hektik.
Dann schauen wir mal.
Doch aufregend wird es
in dieser Familie wohl immer bleiben.
Beim Aufstellen der provisorischen
Liege im Elternschlafzimmer
taucht die Frage auf:
Ist da überhaupt ausreichend Platz
für ihr Bett?
Rolf?
- Ja?
Das passt schon.
Du willst in deinem eigenen Zimmer
schlafen?
Ja, in meinem Zimmer.
- Ganz allein?- Ja.
Here some chocolate.
- Let's see what's in there.
1,08 Mio. Fr.
bezahlen Rolf und Erica Knecht
schlussendlich für ihr Haus.
80'000 Fr. Mehrkosten
wegen ihrer Sonderwünsche.
Viel Geld -
doch wie sagte Erica Knecht?
Man baut nur einmal
und verbringt dann
sein restliches Leben in diesem Haus.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023